and now it's time for bomb reviews with
Chester a are tonight's review Thor the
dark world oh my daddy did a greatest
movie I've ever seen in my life this
filler until Avengers 2 has spoilers
there's this guy named Thor and he's
busy keeping all of the nine realms safe
when he also has a father played by
pirate hannibal lecter and he's like i
think you should take a break story
you're right father that's why I'm gonna
kind of sort of be flirting with warrior
princess here until my other girlfriend
comes into which case I'll chop her like
a rock solid huh it speaking of which
his old girlfriend is trying to get on
with her life surviving the Phantom
Menace isn't easy then she's approached
by her science team who just graduated
from the parents in the transformer
movie art of acting we're here to say
obvious things and funny voices and a
cookie and a girlfriend is like pokey
but one reason for the plot are you here
well our old scientist guy was found
running around naked it's donut what why
comedy comedy but then Thor comes back
to see his girlfriend and she's like
it's a hammer in your pocket are you
just happy to see me
kay Tippi booth you've been gone a long
time creep yeah you know it's funny even
though I'm a guy that I can be smashed
into buildings without getting hurt
apparently a slap from a mortal can
still have my face go in the other
direction we have a lot of plot to get
through so I'm just gonna act like I
love you again
eh okay but then it turns out Asgard is
under attack by Nero from Star Trek and
he's like alright we'll make our ships
invisible so we can just fly by the
gatekeeper of the Rainbow Bridge hello
sir he's bad enough it's okay even
though he can communicate with worlds
far away from our oh and he apparently
can't communicate with a castle it's
just a few miles down the street they
really should have been cellphone - yes
I know for all their science and magic
there's no spell that can make you call
another person and I think he can catch
it a weird one can't you just get the
syrup with you're some kind of a st.
amant well apparently he wants the
girlfriend because she has a magic
entity in her body called the ether
I put either in my body once and by once
I need this many times but it's okay
because Thor's mother is going to
protect her you must kill me Nero from
Star Trek why because I'm an old person
in a scene with my old
we were laughing and having a good time
obviously that means one of us has to
die well who's gonna turn down a free
lunch plans God is defeated by flying
spaceships and lasers and still they
never got cellphones so logically
there's only one thing to do call upon
sexy Tommy what so in a jail cell
I always sexy Tommy what so in a jail
cell once they did things to me it's a
Thora's like I want you to help me but I
need you to wear handcuffs the whole
time
a monkey is like I'm the god of mischief
and mayhem you really think handcuffs
are gonna stop me listen our powers seem
to be very vague and change from time to
time so for now handcuffs are gonna stop
you okay if for any reason I know the
fangirls want to see me in that the soar
Loki go into the dark world which is
more of the dark green world but I won't
split hairs here but Loki pretends he
cuts off Thor's hand I'll never join you
and hands over the girlfriend to Nero
knee rotates the ether out of her but it
turns out it's a trick and Loki Thor
gonna try and destroy the ether now
that's out of her body
oh I'm gonna see now if my hammer can
destroy a dust to like substance doom
come on you cannot destroy a dust like
substance so narrow gets the ether and
destroys Loki ha wait a minute what who
why me back so narrow gets the ether and
destroys Loki you just join Loki Loki
that's like destroying our go from
Family Matters it's like everybody's
favorite character actually come to
think of it maybe we'll be like family
matters don't destroy Loki mule come
back is looky fun seriously the show
really jump the shark at that point I
thought of course takes the death of his
brother very personally oh okay but the
bad news is that Thor and his girlfriend
are now stuck in the dark world but
coincidentally in this gigantic world
that God knows how big it is they just
happen to find the one invisible tiny
part of that world that gets them out
hey remember we were throwing our cheese
and shoes into this black hole that went
nowhere you mean be incredibly long and
unfunny scene yeah like most of the ones
I'm in watch so we can get back let us
journey to the power of improbability so
the really unfunny comic relief comes in
tells them what's going on here from
Star Trek is trying to destroy the
universe because you know it's just what
he does and so if all the nine realms
lined up he could destroy them all and
have control over them all
ever he wants to do because he's a bad
guy so we have the scientific device to
line them all up and we could transport
in between worlds whatever we want this
if it will also allow very heavy things
to suddenly be very light like you could
pick up a car and smash it on someone if
you want it you have to be careful
because animals and people on whatever
you think can just suddenly transport
anywhere and pop up anywhere okay you
just tell me why you're not wearing
pants so that explanation is easy what
comedy oh and I also had a God in my
head that apparently messed me up really
so that's the really late excuse why
you're so crazy even though it never
affected Hawkeye or any other people
ever had a God in their head I told you
comedy yummy can't wait for Black Swan
to throw thorn finds Nero from Star Trek
mug jumping in between all these other
worlds which I can understand that's
totally what feels like when I put ether
in my body
bizarre is like poo the power of fast
editing and confusing science
mumbo-jumbo I win
Daniel a butcher so apparently the day
is won and Thor has to leave his
girlfriend again and you know a comic
relief are like dude he couldn't even
bother to shoot a scene with you saying
goodbye I know right and I had so much
to offer for him like saying science
mumbo-jumbo and fainting not surprised
you did say goodbye to us after all we
had to offer what did you have to offer
comedy Haley yeah hey hey
so Thor goes back to pirate Hannibal
Lecter and he's like I cannot be king
because I'm too horny for a woman I am
Oded yes you are I know I just want to
be sure there was no confusion that I in
fact and Odin okay I'm just gonna walk
out here now I am Loki what Odin okay
that's what I thought you said aha with
me look how long and how did I do it
even though you clearly saw me die in a
previous scene look at Conte's for
adventures - I am Andy Warhol - Toro and
I collect things I have no idea what
that means Bob sure the message boards
will go insane 3 2 was really fun seen
Thor conquer the dark world that brings
up a good point how come so many things
are always from the dark get anything
bad ever come from the cuddly puppy
world the rainbow and sunshine world I
mean aside from any girls cartoon from
the 80s by leaving a catchy theme song
pinup easily no them are ever coming
back
this is jittery boom see shy
gosh I cannot have to get oh I see
you're admiring my bling will I use the
money that I have been saving up over
the years to get the latest model in the
baking cup you will notice the fine
shine the color red though I hear it
gets pulled over by more calves but it's
a color most used by advertisers because
it captures the eye the most so I
appreciate the latest my doing de oh
wait wait hey I still a change
come on I can still look great too the
newest model that's what doesn't even
have four-wheel drive
you